[Music]
[Applause]
well it's Scott Fowler time Charlotte
Observer sports columnist he's been
doing it since
1994 and had some things to say about
David teer the Carolina Panthers owner
find
$300,000 and as Scott says will he take
the punishment to Heart Scott thank you
for joining us thanks Dan I heard what
you said earlier and I I am realizing I
only come on your show when bad things
are happening yeah let me go back to the
incident when you first saw it what was
your
reaction oh gosh when I first saw it I
guess I just dropped my head like oh man
this is here we go here goes the next
three days of my life uh dealing with
this and it has it's been about three
days now so I was not you know terribly
surprised uh because as we call them
around here Tepper Tantrums uh they do
occur but this was a different type it
was far more public and uh just a silly
thing to do what did you think of the
punishment not enough I thought um I
thought the fine I mean Bud Adams uh as
you may have mentioned was F $250,000 in
2009 for shooting the bird twice and 14
years later I feel like inflation should
have
up that plus I think this is more
personal Dan I mean in my Southern
vernacular here I would call such an
incident just plain nasty that was not
cool I mean especially in the postco era
to throw a drink that presumably has
germs on it and stuff uh in the
direction of some people so I would I
thought more like as I wrote in the
column I thought more like a million
dollars might have been a nice round
number here I just kept thinking if you
want to punish a billionaire don't let
him go play with his toys you just say
you can't go to the game cuz 300,000 is
a lot to everybody in America but to a
guy worth 20 billion I I would embarrass
him I would I would give him a timeout
and uh so I thought he got off you with
slap on the wrist with $300,000 that's a
good point the suspension I wondered
about that too Dan so you think he
should have been I I really thought they
were going to probably suspend him for
one game and yeah you know I think he's
embarrassed anyway because I will say
this about Dave teer he likes to
consider himself a man of the people uh
he likes to think of himself as the
billionaire next door as a guy who you
might have a drink with as opposed to
somebody who's going to toss a drink on
someone I think he likes that perception
and so this has hurt I think the
embarrass it's been embarrassing for the
Panthers to have this sort of thing
dominate the news cycle for for for a
day or two uh but certainly a suspension
would have hurt even more why not get
this out earlier why not the team and
teer right away like why are we waiting
two days for this and it and it's not an
apology that he put out he doesn't I
mean he didn't learn anything from this
and yes he's he might be embarrassed
when you blame your passion Scott so
your passion is the reason why all of a
sudden we go okay it's like when Andy
petett was using steroids he said well I
wanted to get back and help my team well
okay everybody gets to use steroids I
mean terer or whoever the pr people they
they tried to sneak this one by the
goalie yeah I I have no idea why two
things one that the word apology wasn't
contained in this three sentence
statement he said he had regret but he
didn't apologize to anyone or just say
I'm sorry America loves to forgive
people we've all seen that I mean but
the road to forgive foress begins with
saying hey man I really messed this up I
am sorry and then you know secondly I
just think it maybe some the Deep
passion thing you think about it the
other way a lot of fans are deeply
passionate so what would happen if a fan
took a drink and threw it on a player an
owner anything a lot lot worse than this
Scott Fowler covers the Carolina
Panthers been a sports columnist in
Charlotte since
1994 um finish this if the Carolina
Panthers had the number one pick in the
draft this
year they would do
what probably trade it for assets I mean
I think I don't think they draft you
know Caleb Williams or something I think
I think of course the new coach will
have a lot to say about this that
they're going to be sold on Bryce young
at least for one more year um of course
they've traded it away to Chicago uh but
what they really need if they if they
were going to use it uh Dan they might
you know if they had it hypothetically
Marvin Harrison or something I mean they
need weapons so badly here they never
score any points they got shut out last
week I mean it's been a horrendous year
in a lot of ways take out the drinks and
everything else they're just a a bad
boring offense but if you're looking at
this team right now as they move forward
um is this a place where a coach wants
to like would Bill bich want to have
this kind of owner I don't think so orim
Harbaugh want to have this kind of
owner Harbaugh and the and the teers
talked last year at least through
intermediaries so maybe but um you know
you'd certainly think the plum here is
where wherever you can go coach Justin
Herbert a valued talent and a and an
obvious NFL star here you got to be sold
not only on Dave terer you got to be
sold on Bryce young because that's
that's the quarterback they're going to
give you so on a rookie contract make it
work you know so so if you're Ben
Johnson or or somebody and you know
they've they fired Dan three different
coaches in six years in the middle of
the season three times that's happened
Ron Rivera Matt rule Frank Reich this
year so that's I think really the real
sticking point if I were a coach I'd be
like I don't want that staying on my
resume I got to have some time I gotta
have some guarantees when Christ
mcaffrey was traded what was the local
reaction in
Carolina
the local reaction was mixed of course
people love mcaffrey and there's still a
lot of 22 jerseys in the stands here in
charot every Sunday but I tell you what
Christian mcaffrey was was very beloved
here and one thing people did say a lot
was H good for Christian McCaffrey's
getting out like been released from Sha
shank or
something and boy has he never you know
I know he's sitting out this week but
he's never been H ever since he since
he's left he's had the best stretch of
his career so I mean people are happy
here I suppose for Christian but that DJ
Moore I mean those were their two best
weapons they're both having career years
and other places this year all right uh
let's take a betat do I get a hold of
Scott Fowler before the start of next
season will there be a reason Marvin you
say yes uh Todd no doubt okay no doubt
Paulie I like Scott but I think uh the
the owner is gonna go silent for a few
months I'm gonna say no okay Satan what
do you think do I get a hold of Scott
Fowler before the start of next season I
believe we do yes okay I do too
Scott well that's I guess
reassuring well you know something bad's
gonna
happen well I'm your man for that yes
yes you are thank you Scott thank you
that's Scott fer Charlotte Observer
sports columnist since 1994 man you got
to have a sense of humor there